I love this like paint omage to
Hollywood in a way you've really grown
up in this industry for you what was the
secret to really coming out the other
side you know always just paying
attention to and being focused on the
craft really and you know we were all at
least for me I was I was always into the
technical side of the business and you
know directing and producing and we're I
was always interested in how the camera
worked in it why this was lit that way
and you know I think if I just stayed
kind of focus on that and didn't let the
partying and all of that that obviously
was there growing up but I just kind of
didn't let it distract me as much as you
know floatium this week announced some
very exciting reboots oh that is coming
back when are we gonna get Drake and
Josh I know you've addressed this but
now I feel like it's gonna actually
happen maybe potentially well I don't
know
you know I've always said it's got to be
something cool and creative I don't want
to just you know bring back in the show
to bring it back you know and and I
think Josh feels the same way it's if
it's something cool and creative then I
think we'd be down but but yeah the
Nickelodeon bringing back all that and
are you afraid of the dark it it's like
my my my little child that my childhood
is like very happy about that do you
think they would ever bring back the
Amanda show possibly I hope so Amanda
said she wants to get back into acting
and she's hysterical so that'd be
awesome
I talked to her recently at all no I
haven't seen her in a while you know
what would be you said it's gonna take a
lot obviously to get you like back in
there but we know that you hang out with
Josh so are there actual conversations
solid conversations happening I don't
know you know we always gonna no no
there's always we always got it we
always you know talk about it but the
actual reality of something like that
happening I mean so many things have to
come into fruition you know and you know
but I mean you know we always we would
always love to work together again so if
the opportunity arises whether it's a
movie or show or anything he came out of
my my cartoon when I was doing
spider-man we worked together there I
wouldn't worked on a grandfather with
him so I don't know if it would be a
reunion or if it would just be some
other cool project that we do that you
know I do some of his YouTube videos
sometimes though so I don't know you
know we like to work together and we
keep it going as long as we can so what
is 2019 look like Rio I just released a
new song called fuego length oh it's my
first song that I'm singing in Spanish I
do a lot of I do a lot of touring all
over the world and my I just have a big
fan base down there and so I did this
song and it's doing really well and then
we just released the video and the
numbers are going up and
and I just recorded a full Spanish
version of the song I'm about to release
so it's exciting and I'm about to go on
on the road right after this to tour it
[Music]